a new patch for Elden ring has added Ray
tracing support to the game on PC
PlayStation 5 and Xbox series X and S
but of course there's a catch according
to Bandai Namco enabling Ray tracing can
have an effect on frame rate and
resolution impacting the overall
performance of the game this isn't
unusual seeing as how Ray tracing is a
fairly resource intensive function but
it's still worth the mention other
changes in the update which is also
available on Xbox one and PlayStation 4
include a number of PVP balance
adjustments General tweaks to the game
world and Ashes of War updates PVP will
see the power of numerous attacks
decreased including two-handed jump
attacks heavy running attacks using
certain weapon archetypes and the
founding reign of star spell has been
toned down the effectiveness of the claw
and Lord of Bloods exaltation Talisman
has also been decreased but the
lifesteal fist skill power has been
increased you can also expect an number
of changes to attribute scaling for
certain weapons adjustments to how
flails work and increase damage for claw
type weapons and while Elden ring is
entering the world of Ray traced light
cyberpunk 2077 is getting ready to
upgrade to a path tracing on April 11th
path tracing is also known as full Ray
tracing which is used to simulate how
light acts in scenes and environments it
traces the way light bounces off objects
in a different way and makes those
scenes and environments hyper realistic
the technology preview at GDC titled
cyberpunk 2077's Ray tracing overdrive
mode shows that virtually all light
sources cast authentic soft shadows and
natural colored lighting reflex
throughout the game's world this results
in more realistic indirect lighting and
occlusion Nvidia explained that the
arrival of GeForce RTX gpus with rt
cores and the AI powered acceleration of
Nvidia dlss allow path tracing to occur
in other update news Diablo 4 has been
all patched up and is ready for this
weekend's open Beta in an official post
on the Diablo 4 forums blizzard outlined
the changes coming to the game's open
Beta issues affecting log in queue times
which peaked at nearly two hours on the
Early Access beta's first day before
becoming virtually non-existent for the
remainder of the Early Access period
have been fixed additionally the
blizzard has fixed an issue that saw cue
timers disappear despite players being
stuck in one an issue affecting spawn
timers for the beta's only World boss
has also been addressed for those
looking to take down the Ferocious Beast
the boss will spawn at 10 am 12 p.m and
10 p.m Pacific time on Saturday March
25th and at 12 a.m Pacific time on
Sunday March 26th one piece of feedback
that blizzard has already received and
will be making action on is The
Barbarians perceived lack of power at
lower levels changes to make the bar
Barbarian more powerful in the early
game will come to the full version of
Diablo 4 when it releases on June 6th
Diablo 4's open Beta weekend starts
tomorrow March 24th and will include two
additional classes Necromancer and Druid
which weren't featured as part of the
Early Access beta in the comment section
let me know if you play any of your game
with Ray tracing on normally I go for
the higher frame rate instead of the
nice shiny Reflections and lights and
all that stuff but let me know where you
land on that and I'll see you tomorrow
thank you